Speaker 1: All right. Let's continue looking
and listening to the sights and sounds yesterday
at the House of Representatives surrounding this
humiliating embarrassment for Republicans where in
they failed after three votes to elect a speaker
of the House. So many interesting things going
on. And I want to start with multiple Republicans
likening Jim Jordan to George Washington. And I'm
not talking about, you know, maybe you think,
oh, is that like my neighbor, George? No,
we're talking about the first president of the
United States. They're comparing Jim Jordan to
George Washington and acting as if there is a
similarity. I can assure you George Washington
would not have looked the other way about alleged
wrongdoing in the wrestling locker room the way
Jim Jordan is accused of doing. But let's put that
aside for a moment. Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
is one of the folks who is defecting seemingly
from supporting Kevin McCarthy for speaker of the
House. She appeared on Where Is This Sean Spicer's
show on Newsmax? And she said, you know, George
Washington did not want to be president, but he
did it because it was right. And it's similar
to Jim to Jim Jordan. Listen to.
Speaker 3: This. There's many people
who we could propose. I am a big proponent of
Lee Zeldin, who actually won us the majority.
Jim Banks is wonderful. Kevin Hearn And would
be an amazing speaker, an amazing leader. Mike
Johnson It could be another option. But also
going back to Jim Jordan, George Washington did
not want to be president of the United States,
but truly did what was right for his country.
Speaker 1: You know, another similarity, George
Washington never told a lie and neither did Jim
Jordan, except when he lied four times about. Did
you speak to Trump on the day of the riots or not?
Hard to imagine a more different individual than
George Washington. Then Republican Congressman
Jim Jordan. And this is the result, quite frankly.
Like I know it's just nonsense that just funnels
right out spews out of Lauren Boebert his mouth
and we could say David the analysis can stop
there. We don't need to go any further. But to
some degree, this sort of stuff is the result
of teaching whatever version of history these
Republicans want to be teaching in school, you
end up thinking a sketchy wrestling coach turned
congressman who yells at every interview is in any
way like the first president of the United States,
George Washington, now. It's also possible that
Bob Baer is mentioning George Washington because
she doesn't know any other historical figures.
Always a possibility with someone as ignorant
as Boebert. But Boebert is not the only one
who is making this George Washington comparison.
Scott Perry, who is Republican elect, congressman
elect from Pennsylvania, he went on Fox News
and he also said, you know, George Washington,
Jim Jordan, there's really something there. Well.
Speaker 2: If you listen to watch the speech that
Jim Jordan gave. Yeah, quite honestly,
most Republicans sat there and said,
oh, my goodness, why isn't this
guy running for speaker? And wow,
I know Jim would be reluctant to remind
everybody. George Washington was reluctant
to what his yet to be called.
Speaker 1: So a reluctant hero,
maybe not the hero they wanted to be, but the hero
that their country demanded that they be. That's
very stupid. Extremely, extremely stupid. And here
is Lauren Boebert later appearing on Fox News.
Bret Beyer mentions, you know, I think it's
possible Jim Jordan not only isn't running
for the job but doesn't want the job and boebert
goes, he may have to do it. He may have to do it.
Speaker 2: And if you heard from him that he
does not want it in any way, shape or form,
what do you say?
Speaker 3: I have
heard that from him. And if we have the numbers,
then sorry, Jim Jordan, we're going to make you
do what's right for the country. We love you.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, it would be very
wrong if Jim Jordan, being speaker of the House is
right, then, I don't know right and wrong anymore.
And I know many in my audience already believe
that. And they write to me all the time saying,
I have no moral compass, but I'm not really
addressing that. I do not believe Jim Jordan is
going to be the speaker of the House. And in fact,
if we pull up and I apologize, I wanted to find
this earlier and I forgot Speaker of the House,
if we look at the betting markets on Speaker
of the House and let's see, there's actually
two different ones here that we can look at.
Okay. If you look at, oh, this is old,
actually, I don't have the numbers. Okay,
folks, I apologize. We if they don't resolve who
the speaker is after today's votes, one of the
elements that I will prepare for you tomorrow. My
lack of professionalism is showing. I will prepare
for you tomorrow. The betting markets on who will
ultimately be the speaker. Care of the house.
Let's now talk about the Fox propaganda machine
and their reaction to this Republican humiliation